[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la place Rouge était vide devant moi
marchait Nathalie il avait un un joli
nom mon
guide
Nathalie la place Rouge était blanche la
neige faisait un tapis et je suivais par
ce froid dimanche Natalie
elle parlait en phrase SOeS de la
Révolution
d'Octobre je pensais
déjà qu'après le t be de l'én on irait
au café
pkine
boire boire un
chocolat la place Rouge était vide j'
pris son bras sour il avait des cheveux
blancs mon guide
[Musique]
natalieie
dans sa chambre à à
l'université une bande d'étudiant
l'attendait
impatiemment on aie on Arie on a
beaucoup parlé il voulait tout savoir
Nathalie
traduisait
Moscou les plaines duucrane et les
champs éisées on a tout mélangé et l'on
a chanté et puis ils ont débouché en
riant à l'avance du champagne de France
a
[Musique]
Dan et quand la chambre fut VI
tous les amis étaient
partis je suis resté seul avec mon
guide
Nathalie n plus question de
phras ni de révolution
d'Octobre on était plus là adieu le
tombeau
de le chocolat de chez Pkin
c'est cétait loin loin
déjà que ma vie me semble vide mais je
sais qu'un jour à Paris c'est moi qui
lui servirai de
guide Nathalie
[Musique]
ouais i I I
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]